[Musique]
m
on les appelle des mathusalem car ces
papillons ont vécu de sept à neuf mois
ils ont quitté le canada en septembre
ils ont parcouru jusqu'à 5000 km passé
tout l'hiver dans le centre du mexique
et ils repartiront vers le nord sous peu
[Musique]
certains ont déjà commencé à se
reproduire leurs rejetons le feront
également dans le sud des états unis
ils vont partir bientôt on commence à
bien connaître ce phénomène
extraordinaire sauf que ces monarques ne
sont pas dans leur sanctuaire habituel
des montagnes de l'état de michoacan les
plus au sud sur les flancs du majestueux
volcan nevado des taux local à quelques
deux heures de la ville de mexico
et ça c'est quelque chose de nouveau et
de surprenant une nouvelle colonie de
monarque jamais vu auparavant qui
témoignent de la résistance de cette
espèce d'exceptionnel de papillons et de
la bonne santé de sa population pourtant
souvent menacés nous ne connaissons pas
soufflé colonies est toujours il ya des
surprises
ce poète cet écrivain mexicain est un
pionnier de l'écologie et le père du
sanctuaire du monarque dans sa région
natale des montagnes du michoacan
reconnu patrimoine de l'humanité par
l'unesco
les monarques sont les salles des morts
que je tourne au monde en forme des
papillons les habitants d'hama nalco sur
le flanc ouest du volcan nevado des
toluca voyez bien des papillons
monarques de temps en temps dans la
région
[Musique]
mais cette fois ci c'est la révélation
dossier et notamment savoir que c'était
une chorale de piedra ici à chorale des
pieds drass c'est une des plus grandes
colonies de monarque dans le pays cette
année on parle de plus ou moins 20
millions de papillons
ils viennent ici parce que ces forêts
sont bien conservées
mais elle n'est pas facile à trouver
cette colonie quelque part à plus de
3000 mètres d'altitude
là où poussent les sapins william l ces
géants aux maigres branchés aux fines
aiguilles le refuge divers des monarques
la montée raide
il n'y a pas de sentiers tracés nous
voici où la colonie se trouvait encore
la veille il y à bien des monarques un
peu partout mais rien de ce qui
ressemble à une colonie celles ci
disposent de tellement d' espaces au
sommet de cette montagne qu'elle se
déplace il n'est pas facile de la
retrouver
nous étions sur le point d'abandonner
quand un des guides de reno neemo a fini
par la localiser un empressement
il a donc fallu redescendre puis remonté
dans une autre direction
il était temps car le soleil commence à
baisser et c'est quand il n'y a plus de
soleil que les papillons viennent
s'agglutiner sur le tronc des oyats
belle on dit que le tronc de ces sapins
dégage de la chaleur la nuit et reste
frais le jour
les monarques aime aussi se rassembler
en énorme grappe aux extrémités des
branches où ils vont passer la nuit
la masse sombre se colore de l'oranje de
leur zèle seulement avec le soleil le
nouvel endroit semble leur convenir
parfaitement cointrin elementos mais
qu'elles sont nécessaires
commençons à avoir et comme sony ne la
laissent et comment ils trouvent tous
les éléments nécessaires à leur survie
ici l'eau de nombreuses sources les
minéraux et le nectar des plantes trois
variétés d'ascq les piannencs leur
unique nourriture
la jaune ces arbustes les plus haut un
peu plus basse la blanche et au ras du
sol la mode ces plantes sont toxiques
les monarques aussi ce qui décourage les
prédateurs enfin presque tous ces
monarques morts ont été la proie
d'oiseaux qui consomme seulement
l'abdomen et laisse la tête et les ailes
toxiques espérer bousculer cette colonie
va attirer des touristes comme on
michoacan mais ici ils seront moins
nombreux une sélection d'idées
d'autant plus que l'accès est vraiment
difficile est difficile d'évoquer la
malle-poste insiste alain daumas
haletant
[Applaudissements]
à monaco est une vaste municipalité mais
avec vingt quatre mille habitants
seulement qui vivent de l'élevage et de
la pisciculture celle de la truite sur
toutes sortes de variétés cette région
magnifique possède 425 sources qui
alimentent les vallées voisines et 30%
de la ville de mexico
les gens vivent aussi de la forêt mais
comme elle est de propriété communale
aucun étranger ne peut venir la coupe et
contrairement au michoacan
elle est bien entretenu car allah pour
eux de la valeur avec les monarques
encore plus mais pour la mairesse pas
question de tourisme de masse c'est
complètement écologique ont tous dit que
sa défaite et que ça respecte la nature
à l'aise à quai ce sera un tourisme
entièrement écologique respectueux de la
nature et qui aidera à la préserver pour
tous et pendant de nombreuses décennies
l'abn montbel homero aridjis n'a pas
encore visité la nouvelle colonie qui ne
fait qu'accroître son admiration pour le
sucre nos monarques cette force de la
nature de son trait system le système
très puissant c'est papillonne fragile
et est très belle mais c'est très fort
la preuve c'est la troisième génération
qui parviendra au canada vers le mois de
juillet où il se reproduira à la fin de
l'été qu'un gamer et j'espère boire
dans les eaux de la lah papillon de
mandat
[Musique]
il